so today I woke up and I thought to
myself I want some dogs welcome guys
now when we were on justy news we did
this article I think a BuzzFeed did it
where they were talking about 22
different ways or 22 different hacks on
what you can get at McDonald's and so I
have my two minions back there Danielle
and Vanessa that are gonna go out and
get those things for me because I'm too
lazy to get it myself
[Music]
BAM fresh fries texture crunchies if you
want the freshest fried to McDonald's
you're supposed to get it with no salt
because they are forced to get you fresh
fries because they're all salted in my
mouth we got it a little late so it's a
little bit stale so I can't really tell
but was it was it pretty fresh meat
about it so tip number one roast out but
I didn't know they actually served boss
water at McDonald's to do the bucket
water at McDonald's but apparently to
order extra large water you should be
able to get it ice but instead we got
this small one the spice effect that we
just spent like the jillion dollars on
food there they wouldn't give it some
extra large water so this one is a myth
so this is a regular cheeseburger and
then you add bacon and eggs
this is the genius breakfast unless
smash together had sex and it's having
fun in my mouth know how to get the
cheapest cheapest Big Mac and get a
double cheeseburger and then you add Big
Mac sauce to it and lettuce
No
well this is a McDouble a hash brown and
a fresh brand new fingerprint edition
look cool so hack number six is a way
for you guys to basically get a sausage
egg McMuffin for a lot cheaper so what
you're going to do is you're going to
order a sausage McMuffin and then you're
going to order the egg on the side so a
sausage McMuffin without the egg is
about a dollar fifty nine so dollar
fifty nine and when you add the egg on
the side is going to be an extra buck so
it ends up being two fifty nine one more
fairly thing for McDonald back number
seven the avocado breakfast sandwich um
this one apparently has guacamole
instead yeah this is not my thing
don't put the egg mcmuffin row number
eight the DIY affogato bing bang pal I
guess this is going to be a caramel
sundae and you get a shot of espresso
and then you get your poor man's off oh
god oh so out the door it's going to be
roughly about 2:30 not too bad
I'm not mad at that hack number 9 the
gourmet is dessert so you're going to
take your McDonald's apple pie and then
let's give this a go gourmet as they say
there's nothing wrong with that dude
number 10 was supposed to be the
in-and-out style animal fries but
McDonald's failed us so you're not going
to see that so I love you McDonald's but
stay pure gamer we're gonna skip number
11 because we were supposed to put a Big
Mac sauce and everything and they say
supposed to be delicious but they didn't
do it for ourselves cue number 12
making your caramel sundae and making it
absolutely delicious and also healthy
you're gonna oh god it's coming up
you're gonna make I'm gonna take your
bag they all mixed together they came up
at the same time to keep weird but do
the chicken green apples and you're
gonna put it in your very healthy soft
serve in caramel the Apple is kind of
moving for me
number 13 french fries with taco bell's
queso dip there's nothing wrong with
cheese and fries we're just gonna just
technique to it you dip it in you swirl
it about like this and you say hello
breasts
you don't want it so it is it tastes
like somebody melted plastic and then
put cheese flavor into it
hack number 14 the dumb [ __ ] hack so
apparently there are a couple people out
there that are complaining that they're
the tropical soft-serve ice cream is too
cold to hold so what you do is you take
off the cap like a little [ __ ]
right and you put it under here so your
dainty little [ __ ] hands don't have to
touch up an ice cold piece of plastic
where the [ __ ] were you born
I guess the mozzarella sticks at
McDonald's failed so we can't really do
the ghetto man or poor man's chicken
parm which I'm very sad about number 16
the Big Mac with bacon
don't the cheese under-17 was supposed
to be frozen coke and ice cream so like
a coke float but apparently they only
had that in Canadia this is America
motor number 18 the deluxe iced coffee
[ __ ]
you take your iced coffee gonna add ice
cream to it you should get it a little
sweet because it's just dairy and ice
water I'm not sure if you ever had ice
cubes in milk before that's what it
tastes like if you don't add a little
sweetness to that was weird
butter not gorgeo berry syrup on the
bottom soft-serve here
crunchy Oreo I might actually might get
this again when I 400 pounds this is
good
I like this hack approved so this is
there I've never had a boat meal from
McDonald's because if you get open for
McDonald's you're obviously eight years
old and you're a loser
not those two are separate though you're
not you're not an eight-year-old losin
your one or the other I'm just gonna do
myself a favor then I'm gonna take this
caramel sundae
okay battlezone
deca you got me again
what's the next one you guys make
grilled cheese oh no one after that is
we go ready to get more bad but what is
this what do you mean this one this is I
don't know which number this is but this
is a hack basically when you get an egg
white mix muffin and you put bacon
inside it so you get a little bacon
treet when you're not real bad let's
take everything that we liked about this
and put it together so one of my
favorite things I liked was being ah the
hash brown and you guys know how much I
love the sausage Egg McMuffin Big Mac
sauce is always great also beef patty
let's put the bacon from the breakfast
sandwich together and here we have it
I like to call this creation the big
mistake
I've done things they should be put
together it's like when you have to
pretty people they have the make a
really ugly baby I can do it I can do it
McDonald's tested david approved
[Music]